[Música]
con emotivos mensajes eeuu recortó los
20 años de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre los peores en su historia las
conmemoraciones tienen un particular
significado este año pues se marca el
final de la guerra más larga de la unión
americana la dea plan instant que se dio
como consecuencia de los ataques
en la víspera del presidente joe biden
hizo un llamado a la unidad y rechazó el
resentimiento contra los estadounidenses
musulmanes que creció luego de que se
responsabilizará a yihadistas vinculados
a al qaeda de los atentados hablamos con
uno de ellos para saber cómo cambió su
vida después del 11-s
noveno fin de semana de protestas contra
el pase sanitario en francia el
movimiento de los chalecos amarillos que
sacudió al país en 2018 rechazando el
alza en los precios del combustible
también se unió a la movilización cerca
de 200 manifestaciones están convocadas
en toda francia
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz iniciamos en eeuu
donde se conmemoran los 20 años de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre con
homenajes los estadounidenses recordaron
las casi tres mil vidas que se perdieron
cuando cuatro aviones secuestrados por
terroristas impactaron contra las torres
gemelas en nueva york la sede del
pentágono en virginia y un campo abierto
en shanksville pensilvania el presidente
joe biden si bien no dio ningún discurso
visitó cada uno de los lugares atacados
aurora valle nos cuenta más detalles
sobre el desarrollo de la ceremonia
en la ciudad de nueva york en un día
soleado similar al de hace 20 años
eeuu rindió homenaje a las 3000 víctimas
del ataque que conmocionó al mundo
se dio inicio a la ceremonia a las 8 46
de la mañana momento en el que el primer
avión secuestrado fue estrellado contra
la torre norte del world trade center
ese 11 de septiembre de 2001 el actual
mandatario joe biden y los ex
presidentes barack obama y bill clinton
se unieron a los familiares de las
víctimas para marcar un minuto de
silencio
y mi memoria se remonta a ese terrible
día en el que parecía que un espectro
maligno había descendido sobre nuestro
mundo pero también fue un momento en el
que muchas personas actuaron por encima
de lo normal empezando por las
tripulaciones de los vuelos como sara
water
después los familiares comenzaron a
recitar los nombres de las casi 3.000
víctimas mortales un ritual anual que se
prolongó durante varias horas
només ha culminado
en una ceremonia más pequeña a altos
mandos militares rindieron homenaje a
los muertos del pentágono prometiendo
continuar con su legado de protección de
la nación el ex presidente george bush
que estaba en el cargo cuando se
produjeron los atentados asistió por su
parte al acto conmemorativo desde
shanksville donde se estrelló el vuelo
93 de united airlines
en las semanas y meses que siguieron al
11-s me sentí orgulloso de dirigir a un
pueblo impresionante resistente y unido
hablando de la unidad de eeuu esos días
parecen haber quedado atrás una fuerza
maligna parece actuar en nuestra vida
cotidiana convirtiendo cada desacuerdo
en una disputa y cada discusión en un
choque de culturas
falsos
en dos décadas los atentados yihadistas
más mortíferos de la historia están ya
anclados en la memoria colectiva de eeuu
pero el dolor de las familias de las
víctimas y de los supervivientes sigue
siendo agudo
el ataque que fue perpetrado por
yihadistas vinculados a al-qaeda hizo
que creciera el resentimiento contra los
musulmanes estadounidenses en el país el
presidente joe biden hizo un llamado a
la unidad y rechazó la islamofobia en
france24 hablamos con wilfredo arm ruiz
quien es musulmán y vive en eeuu le
consultamos qué significado tiene el 11
de septiembre y si el trato de la gente
cambio hacia él después de esta fecha
para mí significa en varias cosas porque
para mí para la comunidad de musulmanes
aquí en norteamérica significa un día
donde hubo una perdida porque nosotros
también somos norteamericanos nos
sentimos americanos y en ese sentido
nos tocó nos afectó murieron decenas y
decenas de musulmanes más de 80
musulmanes en septiembre 11
musulmanes de nuestras comunidades
fueron rescatistas los días post
septiembre 11 y así por el estilo
nuestra comunidad
tiene entonces otro obtuvo otra
repercusión además de sufrir el ataque
como un ataque en el que nosotros mismos
fuimos víctimas también
fue la singular y la singuralidad
singularización de los musulmanes en
norteamérica como par como que si
tuviese en algún tipo de responsabilidad
o solidaridad con ese tipo de actos y
también
desde ese entonces la islamofobia
comenzó a
afianzarse
lamentablemente afectó a nuestros niños
en las escuelas a nuestros los de las
personas en los trabajadores en sus
lugares de trabajo a toda la comunidad
cuando viaja ya no es
niños que aparecen en listas para no
viajar de apenas 34 años de listas de
sospechosos con sospechosos de que
verdad pero así por el estilo esto
pasado 20 años desde septiembre 11
han sido toda una especie de
transformación para nuestra comunidad de
desert singularizada estará aislada
hacer una comunidad mucho más abierta
mucho más
ávida de participar cívicamente en todos
los aspectos sociales políticos y
económicos de las de la sociedad en los
eeuu y es que miles de emigrantes
indocumentados la mayoría procedentes de
américa latina se prestaron como
voluntarios para ayudar a limpiar la
zona devastada desconociendo los
peligros para su salud muchos de ellos
aún sin documentos ahora lidian con
enfermedades marinas ardilla nos cuenta
más
hace 20 años cuando una nube espesa de
polvo cubrió nueva york unos 3000
migrantes indocumentados latinos se
prestaron como voluntarios para limpiar
la devastada zona zero como esta
colombiana que trabajó durante 8 meses
en la limpieza de los edificios
colindantes al world trade center sentir
la necesidad de ayudar no estaba
ayudando aquí
venir a la rescatada a ver que podía
hacer
por eso muy importante me sentía sentía
que tenía que estar aquí
trabajamos de romper se encontró se
encontrará cuerpos también pero a su vez
zapatos en 2001 un 27 de la población
newyorkina era hispana tras los
atentados muchos migrantes
indocumentados ayudaron en la limpieza
de las 18 toneladas de escombros con la
promesa de legalizar su estatus uno se
ofreció a ir a trabajar una pregunta
residente
dos décadas después la decepción es
evidente la comunidad latina te enteras
que nos iban a ayudar porque yo creo una
cosa de verdad que estoy muy
discriminada algunos fueron deportados y
algunos de nuestro grupo dijeron no
mejor yo irme si es que voy a morir
mejor me voy para mi país por lo menos
estoy con mi familia por lo menos tengo
un techo además en ese momento nadie era
consciente de los peligros para la salud
que acarreaba la exposición al polvo
tóxico que como se demostró más tarde
derivó en graves enfermedades
respiratorias y cancerígenas muchos
migrantes no acudieron al médico por
miedo a ser deportados desde ese
fatídico día rubiel aparece sinusitis
asma ansiedad y vértigos
de que la gente nueva no llegando al
papel es una justicia porque se perdió
lo más preciado que la salud y no hay
plata que valga si leen a 1 500 mil y un
millón lo que sea y mi plata que valgan
la salud no tiene precio como cada
aniversario estas mujeres reivindican su
papel en un dramático momento de la
historia de eeuu en el que ellos
volvieron a ser unos héroes sin derechos
sobreviviendo
y
cambiamos de tema y pasamos a américa
latina' los chilenos recordaron los 48
años del golpe de estado-militar llevado
a cabo por el entonces jefe del ejército
augusto pinochet decenas de personas
rindieron homenaje al fallecido
presidente salvador allende en el
monumento en su honor ubicado en el
centro de la capital y se prevén más
actos conmemorativos durante la jornada
los homenajes se celebran a puertas de
unas elecciones presidenciales y la
elaboración de una nueva constitución
que reemplace a la que se heredó de la
dictadura de pinochet
34,3 millones de argentinos están
convocados a las urnas este domingo para
las elecciones primarias que definirán
la lista de candidatos de los comicios
del 14 de noviembre en los que se
renovarán 127 de los 257 escaños de la
cámara de diputados y 24 de las 72
bancadas del senado
estarán habilitados más de 17.000
centros de votación en todo el país en
argentina el voto es obligatorio para
los ciudadanos de 18 a 69 años el
gobierno aseguro que se activaron los
protocolos sanitarios necesarios para
que ir a votar no representa un riesgo
por la pandemia desde buenos aires-
nuestro correo natalie cosoi tiene los
detalles
la función de estas primarias en las que
es obligatorio votar excepto para los
menores de 18 años aquellos que tienen
entre 16 y 17 años pueden votar pero no
es obligatorio tampoco es obligatorio
para los mayores de 70 decía el objetivo
de estas elecciones es que las fuerzas
puedan decidir cuál de sus listas si
presentan más de una será la que compita
el 14 de noviembre en las elecciones
legislativas propiamente dichas algunas
y algunos partidos no presentan más de
una lista así que también sirve como una
forma de medir fuerzas entre los
diferentes partidos de cara al 14 de
noviembre y también para que la
población los ciudadanos entiendan cuál
es el mapa que se empieza a dibujar de
cara a esas elecciones y tal vez
reflexionen de forma diferente respecto
a cómo quieren votar como este año las
elecciones son en el contexto de
pandemia algunas medidas para tratar de
prevenir y evitar los contagios por un
lado se han sumado centros de votación
para distribuir más a los votantes
también se va a pedir que la gente esté
respetando una distancia de dos metros
entre sí mientras espera para votar que
lleve su propio bolígrafo
será para las anotaciones que tengan que
hacer y se va a evitar el contacto entre
entre votantes y autoridades de mesa lo
más posible también abre un horario
especial durante la mañana para aquellas
personas que son de riesgo las mesas se
abren para la votación a las 8 de la
mañana de argentina se cierran a las 18
horas también de argentina y a las 23 se
espera que estén los primeros resultados
en una prisión de máxima seguridad murió
este sábado los 86 años el veterano
fundador del grupo terrorista sendero
luminoso abimael guzmán de acuerdo con
las autoridades penitenciarias guzmán
falleció por complicaciones en su estado
de salud cumplía cadena perpetua tras
haber sido detenido en 1992 junto a la
cúpula del grupo señalado como el
responsable de la mayor parte de los 69
mil muertos que dejó el conflicto entre
los años
1980 y 2000 en el país
y miles de personas se manifiestan
contra el pase sanitario por noveno fin
de semana consecutivo en diferentes
ciudades de francia el documento es
exigido para ingresar a lugares de ocio
y a trabajadores de la salud y válida la
vacunación o una prueba negativa de kobe
19 las autoridades calculan que cerca de
170 mil personas están hoy o están
llamadas a las calles de todo el país
informe de manuel a cano
no más pase sanitario es la demanda que
comparten las 200 manifestaciones
convocadas en varias ciudades de francia
por noveno sábado consecutivo
en parís cientos de empleados sanitarios
se manifiestan en frente al ministerio
de salud consideran que la exigencia de
la vacuna para trabajar es
antidemocrático usted se da cuenta de lo
que es un cuidador que ha metido a
pacientes en bolsas para cadáveres que
se enfrenta al abuso institucional que
sufre en su trabajo y al que le dicen tú
sigue vacuna te de todos modos si no te
vacunas te suspenderán te quedarás sin
sueldo que país democrático hace eso el
gobierno francés anunció que a partir
del 15 de septiembre todos los empleados
de hospitales y residencias de ancianos
podrán ser suspendidos sin pagos si no
han recibido al menos una dosis
y trabajé siendo positiva para kobe
asintomática fui a trabajar todos los
días incluso 40 a 45 horas y no fue un
problema para nadie realmente para nadie
y hoy por no ponerme esta inyección me
piden que me vaya aunque tenga buena
salud para atender a mis pacientes
mientras que entre los ciudadanos hay
preocupación por los supuestos efectos
secundarios de los fármacos
el hecho de vacunar a los niños desde
los 12 años me preocupa porque no
conocemos las consecuencias de esta
vacuna porque no es una vacuna es una
inyección no conocemos las consecuencias
a largo plazo esto para alicante
el pase sanitario entró en vigor el 9 de
agosto se trata de un documento que
confirma que una persona fue vacunada
contra él con 19 o tiene una prueba con
resultado negativo de menos de 72 horas
y es exigido además para ingresar a
lugares de ocio y trenes de largas
distancias la policía de israel arrestó
a otros dos de los ciudadanos palestinos
que se habían fugado de una cárcel de
máxima seguridad esta semana lo que
eleva el número de fugitivos
recapturados a cuatro de seis los
arrestados habían sido condenados o eran
sospechosos de supuestamente planear
atentados contra israél
los arrestos llegan tras una
cinematográfica fuga que expuso las
profundas fallas del sistema penal y
convirtió en héroes a los palestinos
hasta aquí esta informativa en flash 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www punto frente 4 puntocom
para seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias quédense con nosotros
[Música]